the physical appearance um aliens seems
to be pretty consistent it's like the
most
stereotypical like the big large eyes
the tiny mouth and nose the little kind
of Elf I feel like I want to believe
that's just sort of a hokey
stereotype however there's some
credibility to how widely consistent
that is as far as what aliens look like
the way I think about is on Earth
intelligent life we have us shaped like
this then there's octopus that are
nothing like us and then even a dolphin
being a mammal looks so different than
us it seems absurd that anything coming
from another planet would look anything
like us do you know how to feed a baby
panda you get in a panda suit and you go
feed it I see where you're going with
that yeah man the true form is being
hidden we might be encountering what
they want us to see them as that makes
sense to me and it could be weirder than
that